felt like I was going to the principal
office man and you I had to walk up
these stairs to get to George Payton
office and you know I get up there I go
in the room and George had like this
little button to like close the door and
then he just got straight into it he's
like well let's take his glasses off put
him down I want to let you know that we
are trading you to Los Angeles Rams and
I said whoa like
because in Frio you see you get a chance
to say goodbye you know when you get
traded it's just like boom you get 45
minutes pack up your stuff that you want
to take now and then we're going to ship
everything else to you you don't get no
chance to say no goodbye crazy it ain't
that ain't true that ain't true when I
got cut like it was the conversation we
had then walk downstairs try to say
goodbye to everybody real quick and once
you walk out of that building you can't
come back it's over